- You've had mixed reactions
from people about Princeton, right?
- Yes.
- How is that? How do you deal with that?
- Well, you know, we get a lot of stares.
It's rare where we're from
to see African American
families with Caucasian babies.
- Bye.
- [Female Guest] (laughs) He's gone again.
And so, we get a lot of stares.
I've had the police called
on me where I've had to
- [Kelly] What?
- Yes, show documentation
that he's my son.
- Do you get mad at that?
I would get mad at that.
- You know, we try to just,
kind of push it to the side
and just choose to love.
- [Kelly] It's almost like you'd rather
somebody just say something.
- [Female Guest] Right.
- Like, instead of like don't stare at me.
I get that it might be weird
but just say something.
- Right. It's just easier to say.
- [Kelly] I didn't
steal this kid. (laughs)
- [Female Guest] I know, I know.
- There goes Aiden going after
- [Female Guest] Right.
- [Kelly] Y'all are gonna be performers.
It's your stage y'all! It's your stage.
- And I'm not the babysitter
because I get that a lot too.
- [Kelly] Oh gosh, oh my gosh.
- Yes, yes. Yep.
- [Kelly] People are rude.
That's like coming up to
ask if someone's pregnant.
Don't do it.
- [Male Guest] No, no. (audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Don't do it, it's rude.
- In all fairness, my wife is white
and so we have biracial kids
and she gets the same thing.
You have a white wife
and my kids, you know,
they look, they're black.
So, sometimes she's at the airport and
they're questioning the kid,
it was a couple years ago,
and the kid, she couldn't
talk at the time.
They assume that the
babysitter or something,
it's just, it's awkward and sometimes...
- That's so weird, we're
such a multicultural,
- [Male Guest] It's annoying.
- American's a melting pot of everyone.
- [Male Guest] Yeah.
- You see it everywhere, I feel like.
- [Male Guest] It's annoying.
- (audience clapping) I love
that about America. Yeah.
This is what I love too.
You're open to keeping in contact
with all the biological parents, right?
- Yes.
- I think that that's a really cool thing.
- Yes, it has to be.
You know, I think that
it's really important
to keep them connected
to their birth families.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I call it my bonus families.
I don't want to ever put
my children in a position
to where they're questioning
well why didn't you, you know?
Uh-uh, no.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, I would rather them know
and especially that one.